Here's some amazing news: A new study found
that after more than 35 million bike share
trips in the United States, nobody's died.
Regular bike rides are much riskier: 21 of
every 100 million trips are fatal.
Bikeshares are an increasingly popular way
of getting around: systems have popped up
in dozens of cities in the past decade.
And fewer people get injured on bike shares
too – In DC, the collision rates are 35%
lower than for regular bikes
So why would bike shares be safer? A few reasons.
First, they tend to be designed with safety
in mind. So this was is a lot heavier, with
a low center of gravity. This one is a lot
lighter. This one has really wide tires, this
one has thin tires.
Which makes it hard to go very fast.
And that means you’re less likely to topple
over when you hit a bump or a pothole.
Plus, the bike’s bright colors, flashing
lights and upright seating make riders easier
to see.
The second reason is about where bike shares
are.
Bike share stations are mostly located in
dense, urban areas with lots of foot traffic.
And drivers tend to be going more slowly.
They’re already on the lookout for pedestrians
So cyclists are safer.
And third, people who use bike share tend
not to be very experienced cyclists.
And weirdly enough, this can be a good thing,
because it means they’re more cautious riders.
People are less likely to wear helmets. Now,
that might make you think, oh, they're more
dangerous. But it actually could be the opposite.
One study found that passing drivers stayed
further away from cyclists who didn't have
a helmet.
But if you do get in a crash, wearing a helmet
significantly lowers your odds of a head injury.
So if you have a helmet, it's a really good
idea to wear one. But, if you don't, your
mom's not watching, and the odds, well, they
are  in your favor
So, there has been one death in Mexico and two in Canada
But, as the study notes, the injury rates there are way
lower for bike shares than for regular bike riding